♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
WE REPORTED ON THE SO-CALLED
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN AND HOW
IT’S REALLY A BLUE STATE BAILOUT
BUT EVEN WORSE THAN THAT.
THERE ARE STRINGS ATTACHED TO
THE OVER THREE AND A BILLION
DOLLARS GIVEN TO STATES AND
LOCALITIES BURIED ONE OF THEM IS
NO NEW TAX CUTS.
IT STOPS STATES FROM DOING TAX
CUTS BUT HERE IS TO DISCUSS ALL
OF THAT AND MORE TENNESSEE
SENATOR MARSHA BLACKBURN.
LET’S GET TO BIDEN’S BAILOUT IN
A SECOND BUT I JUST LOVE YOUR
REACTION TO THE NEWS THAT WE
REPORTED IN THE TOP OF THE SHOW,
PRESIDENT BIDEN FINALLY SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT ANDREW CUOMO,
TOTALLY INADEQUATE AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER BUT WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON WHERE THE CUOMO
SCANDAL STANDS TONIGHT?
>> I TELL YOU, I THANK YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT IS INADEQUATE.
THERE ARE GROWING CALLS BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF LEGISLATION
AT THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL WHO ARE CALLING FOR HIM TO
RESIGN AND PROBABLY HE SHOULD BE
LISTENING MORE TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THERE IN ALBANY AND
SPENDING LESS TIME TRYING TO
PLEAD HIS CASE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
STEVE: I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT AND NOT
JUST REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS WHAT IS INTERESTING
ABOUT THE WAY DEMOCRATS FINALLY
WEIGHING IN BUT STILL NOTHING
FROM VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS AS I
NOTED EARLIER BUT THE GREAT
CHAMPION OF THE MEAT TO MOVEMENT
AND YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT FROM
THOSE HEARINGS.
SENATOR, LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
BAILOUT BILL.
IT SEEMS TO ME THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT, THE REQUIREMENT THAT IT
STATES TAKE ANY OF THE BAILOUT
MONEY THAN THEY ARE FORBIDDEN OR
CAN BE STOPPED BY THE TREASURY
SECRETARY FROM IMPLEMENTING TAX
CUTS IN THEIR STATES.
THAT’S A BLATANT FEDERAL POWER
GRAB AND THAT’S LIKE VERY
BLATANT BUT IT SEEMS TO BE THE
WHOLE THING IS A FEDERAL POWER
GRAB.
>> YES, YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT’S A FEDERAL POWER GRAB.
STATES, WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO, IS GO FOR CONTROL AND POWER
OVER ALL THE STATES IN THE
CITIES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FORCE THEIR
WILL AND CENTRALIZE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THIS IS THE WAY
THEY ARE GOING ABOUT IT AND IF
YOU TAKE SOME MONEY THEN YOU
CANNOT CUT TAXES.
THE REASON THEY ARE DOING THIS,
I THINK, IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SEVERAL STATE LEGISLATORS THIS
YEAR THAT ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT
TENNESSEE DID PROBABLY 20 YEARS
AGO WHICH IS TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WE NEVER HAVE A STATE
INCOME TAX AND EVEN PUTTING IT
IN OUR STATE CONSTITUTION IN
2014 IN THE FORM OF AN AMENDMENT
BUT SEE, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WANTS TO TAX YOU SO THAT THEY
HAVE MORE OF A SPEND.
IF THEY GIVE MONEY TO YOUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THEY WANT YOU TO BE
BEHOLDEN TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT DOESN’T MATTER IF IT IS
TELLING YOU HOW YOU CAN TAX,
WHEN YOU CONTACTS, IT DOESN’T
MATTER IF IT IS TELLING YOU HOW
YOU’RE GOING TO RUN ELECTIONS,
IT DOESN’T MATTER IF IT’S ABOUT
GUN RIGHTS, WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IS TAKE CONTROL AND
MICROMANAGE EVERY CITY, EVERY
COUNTY AND EVERY STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
STEVE: IT’S INTERESTING BECAUSE
AS I HEAR YOU TALK IT REMINDS ME
OF THE EE VIEW.
THEY HAVE THIS POLICY OF
STOPPING TAX COMPETITION AS THEY
CALL IT WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT
STOPPING COUNTRIES LIKE THE UK
FROM CUTTING TAXES TO MAKE
THEMSELVES MORE COMPETITIVE.
VERY QUICKLY, SENATOR, IS THERE
ANYTHING WE CAN DO?
SO MUCH OF THESE ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SO CAN WE FIGHT
THIS CASE LEGALLY?
>> YOU WILL SEE SOME OF THE
STATES THAT WILL TAKE THIS GO TO
COURT AS WELL AS THEY SHOULD.
LEGISLATIVELY YOU WILL SEE US
BEGIN TO GO BACK IN AND FILE
LEGISLATION TO PAIR SOME OF
THESE PROVISIONS THAT WERE STUCK
INTO THIS BILL IN ORDER TO GIVE
THE DEMOCRATS CONTROL.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS TO
DOMINATE AND TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THERE TO BE A
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM.
THEY WANT TO RUN THE WHOLE SHOW
AND THEY ARE USING THIS HR ONE
AND OTHER PIECES OF LEGISLATION,
SUCH AS DEFUND THE POLICE IN
ORDER TO CENTRALIZE THEIR POWER